In the previous part of this lesson, we’ve
seen why a convex lens is called a
CONVERGING lens!
Now let’s discuss the concave lens in detail!
It refracts the light in a similar way!
A ray of light after entering the concave
lens bends TOWARDS the normal and when it
again enters air, it bends AWAY
from the normal.
Will the concave lens behave in the same way
as the convex lens?
Will the rays
converge after refracting from a concave lens?
If the rays from a point object are incident
on a concave lens, then after
refraction, they do NOT converge at a single
point.
These refracted rays
DIVERGE.
It means they go away from each other.
But wait…
Since they do not
intersect at a common point, does that mean
no image is formed?
Well the image IS formed!
If we were to extend all these rays backward,
they
all meet at this point.
The virtual image is formed at this point!
So this is a pattern by which concave lens
refracts rays of light.
It diverges all
the light coming from a point.
Hence it is called a DIVERGING lens!
Now let’s look at both the lenses side by
side!
So the convex lens CONVERGES all the light
rays from a point object, and the
concave lens DIVERGES all the light rays from
a point object.
But usually our objects are big and not just
a single point!
So let’s use an arrow
to denote an object.
We can take points on the arrow and find out
the image
for each point.
Finally we join all the image points together
to get the complete
image.
This is a real and inverted image!
This is the image formed for an object when
a
convex lens is used!
Are the object and image of the same size?
What will happen if I change the
position of the object?
Will the position of the image change?
Will the size of
the image change?
In order to know the answers to these questions,
keep watching our future
videos!